bonjour à tous et bienvenue en direct
sur Public Sénat et on commence par
l'information de la nuit le Sénat a
supprimé le compte pénibilité dans le
cadre de l'examen du projet de loi sur
la simplification de la vie des
entreprises
187 sénateurs UMPS et sont tristes ont
voté pour sa disparition contre 152 pour
la gauche le compte pénibilité est une
des mesures phares de la réforme des
retraites très critiquées par le MEDEF
qu'il a juge inapplicable et anxiogène
pour les entrepreneurs et on reste au
Sénat où se prépare aussi l'examen du
projet de loi déjà adopté par les
députés sur la transition énergétique ce
matin c'est le climatologue jean-jouzel
qui a été entendu par les sénateurs pour
lui il est encore possible de ne pas
augmenter la température de 2 degrés
comme le préconise le rapport du GIEC on
écoute
si on continue sur l'interrupteur sur
lequel nous sommes nous risquons d'aller
vers 4 degrés en moyenne à la fin du
siècle et ça se poursuivra par la suite
quand on regarde l'augmentation de
l'effet de serre elle est pour les trois
quarts liée à notre utilisation des
combustibles c'est le deuxième point
important du rapport c'est que la
température de stabilisation à long
terme celle dont on parle dans cet
accord climat c'est-à-dire les deux
degrés directement proportionnels à la
quantité cumulée de gaz carbonique parmi
les trajectoires possibles c'est de
diviser par deux voire par trois les
émissions à horizon 2050 comment
efficacité énergétique pas de surprise
renouvelable nucléaire et du stockage
piège du gaz carbonique
de déontologie la première réunion avait
lieu ce matin assez l'UMP
jean-jacques-est qui en est le président
le sénateur de la Seine-et-Marne qui
s'insurge contre le tous pourris on
l'écoute au micro de Quentin calmé
le Sénat a choisi pour examiner les
problèmes
de conflits d'intérêt en fait c'est pas
les incompatibilités c'est une autre
question pour les conflits d'intérêts à
choisir de créer un comité déontologique
et non pas un déontologue extérieur on
dit beaucoup de choses des
parlementaires ils sont de la tous
pourrie c'est pas vrai d'abord c'est
complètement faux la plupart des la
grande la très grande majorité des
parlementaires est honnêtes quelquefois
elle est imprudente il y a certains qui
sont imprudents mais je crois qu'ils ne
savent pas il faut leur apprendre les
règles déontologiques et se poser
toujours la question de de la
déontologie
le budget de la Sécurité sociale examiné
et en commission ce matin environ 200
buralistes ont par ailleurs manifesté
devant le Sénat pour dénoncer la hausse
des taxes sur les cigares et cigarillos
et plus généralement contre la politique
du gouvernement sur le tabac on écoute
le président de la Fédération des
buralistes d'Île-de-France
notre message était non une augmentation
des taxes de 216 % et pour que le marché
continue
à travailler et que les gens ne pas
chargé en cigare Luxembourg qui c'est
bizarre mais Luxembourg a baissé ses
taxes donc c'est pour pas qu'on meurt
aussi parce que aujourd'hui le marché
est déjà n'est pas facile et on a déjà
perdu 870 buralistes cette année et ça
pourrait être beaucoup plus grave dans
cet inquiétant
et pour parler du budget de la Sécurité
sociale tam-train nous a rejoint sur ce
plateau bonjour Thomas bonjour Delphine
alors le texte a été examiné ce matin en
commission une soirée examinée en séance
lundi 10 novembre à partir de 14h30
quels sont les modifications apportées
par les sénateurs sur ce texte parce que
très clair c'est que c'est un budget de
la Sécurité sociale de droite qui va
être examinée par le Sénat la semaine
prochaine le texte de l'Assemblée
nationale a été considérablement
modifiée 55 amendements ont été adoptés
ce matin notamment à l'initiative du
rapporteur le centreiste Jean-Marie
wonderenberg également le président de
la commission des affaires sociales
l'UMP Jean alain Milon alors l'objectif
de tout ça en tout cas c'est bien de
voter de faire adopter ce texte plutôt
de droite donc dans son intégralité au
Sénat rappelons que ça va être une
première depuis trois ans puisque depuis
trois ans tous les textes budgétaires
ont été repoussés par le Sénat faute de
majorité étant donné à fragile majorité
de gauche à l'époque alors que de la
droite Tam qu'est-ce que ça veut dire un
budget de la Sécurité sociale de droite
et ben écoutez déjà elle propose sa
mesure phare 1 milliard d'économies avec
tout d'abord toute une série de mesures
qui sont comme ça plutôt consensuelles à
rendre les soirs moi redondants pour
supprimer les soins également
inutiles par exemple en organisation en
organisant mieux les rapports entre le
médecin traitant et l'hôpital on prend
un exemple tout simple votre médecin
vous fait faire un examen une prise de
sang une radio sur cette base il décide
de vous hospitaliser et puis quand vous
arrivez à l'hôpital on vous fait faire
exactement les mêmes examens et bien
c'est exactement ce que les sénateurs
veulent faire en sorte de ne plus avoir
il propose pour cela la mise en place
d'un dossier médical biologique où tout
le monde comme ça pourrait partager et
bien ces données ils estiment que c'est
plutôt facile aujourd'hui puisque toutes
ces données bien sont déjà numérisées
rappelons tout de même que ça ressemble
au dossier médical personnel un dossier
qui part du même principe mais qui est
beaucoup plus ambitieux c'est un
véritable carnet de santé informatisé
pour l'instant c'est un échec plutôt
consensuelles parce que
la droite propose aussi des mesures que
la gauche va rejeter ah ben oui
évidemment d'abord et bien la mesure
phare de la gauche la modulation des
allocations familiales selon les revenus
ça là-dessus la droite considère que
c'est une véritable attaque contre les
familles puis que ça va à l'encontre de
l'universalité de ce type de prestations
ça en plus tout de même le budget de 400
à 700 millions d'euros par an il faut
donc trouver des économies et là-dessus
la droite a également ses idées alors
parmi les propositions qui vont
certainement susciter des débats dans
l'hémicycle il y a d'abord la retraite à
64 ans en 2024 ou encore la suppression
de la journée de carence dans la
Fonction publique mesure qui avait été
rétabli par la gauche dès l'arrivée de
François Hollande au pouvoir rien que
dans les hôpitaux ça pourrait rapporter
70 millions et puis toute une série de
mesures encore sur les génériques les
achats groupés de vaccins la
tarification des urgences de l'hôpital
ou encore la lutte contre la fraude
enfin sachez que la droite compte lors
de l'examen de ce PLFSS titiller la
gauche sur les économies qu'elle prévoit
pour la nouvelle majorité le budget du
gouvernement est très très optimiste le
compte n'y est pas merci beaucoup Tam et
on vous retrouve à 19h en attendant je
vous propose tout de suite de suivre
l'audition de François recemel le
ministre du Travail est entendu par les
sénateurs de la commission des affaires
sociales mais cette voix sur le volet
emploi du PLF le projet de loi de
finance pour 2015 on se retrouve tout à
l'heure
et on a même pas eu le quart d'heure
bourguignon donc voilà je salue le
rapporteur et l'ensemble des membres de
la commission mesdames Messieurs les
sénatrices sénateurs je l'ai dit
effectivement vous l'avez rappelé
monsieur le Président j'ai évoqué avant
hier soir à l'Assemblée nationale le
budget 2015 de la mission travaille
emploi d'un budget
d'exigence auquel j'ai fixé trois
objectifs
la lutte contre le chômage priorité
numéro 1 faire mieux avec à peu près
autant
et répondre efficacement à ou le plus
efficacement possible à l'urgence du
moment
exigences à l'égard des demandeurs
d'emploi donc exigences à l'égard du
service public de l'emploi exigences à
l'égard des entreprises c'est un budget
d'exception car c'est un budget dans un
contexte que vous connaissez de
réduction importante de la dépense
publique qui est globalement stable vous
avez indiqué Monsieur le Président
quelques modifications ont été apportées
l'autre soir et il s'élève donc à 11,3
milliards d'euros
contre
11,4 milliards d'euros l'année dernière
soit une baisse d'environ 1%. le premier
principe donc améliorer notre
intervention sans augmenter les moyens
c'est à dire être plus efficace
je parlerai de Pôle Emploi ces moyens
nous les avons accordé à Pôle emploi
depuis 2012 puisque 2012-2013 c'est 4000
emplois supplémentaires qui sont venus
renforcer les équipes existantes
maintenant il faut faire mieux avec ce
que l'on a et qui est sanctuarisé pour
l'année
2015 le budget de Pôle Emploi est
effectivement
sanctuarisé j'y reviendrai à hauteur de
d'un peu plus de 1500 millions d'euros
19 très exactement 1519 dans le cadre de
la convention tripartite avec une édité
Pôle emploi il s'agira d'améliorer
l'accompagnement des demandeurs d'emploi
tout en développant une offre spécifique
pour les plus petites entreprises nous y
travaillons un budget constant atteindre
ces objectifs nécessitera c'est vrai une
mise en œuvre progressive et bien
déficience et des redéploiements à
l'intérieur de Pôle Emploi deuxième
sujet
des moindres l'insertion par l'activité
économique je sais que vous y êtes
attaché les uns les autres moi-même
aussi le financement de l'insertion par
l'activité économique ces 240 millions
qui seront consacrés un effort de plus
de 40 millions d'euros depuis 2012 et
une indexation mais vous le savez cela
sur l'évolution du SMIC qui entrera en
vigueur dès 2015 au total c'est un
effort de 820 millions d'euros en
incluant les 580 millions d'euros pour
les contrats aidés dans le domaine de
l'IAE qui sont en cours de
transformation en aide au poste et la
réforme de l'IAE qui va entrer qui entre
en vigueur change la donne avec un
financement sous forme d'aide au poste
qui était demandé d'ailleurs par les
structures de l'IAE entreprise
d'insertion chantier de l'île
d'insertion qui rendra le financement du
secteur plus dynamique
avec une part variable qui sera fonction
de la réalisation des objectifs et du
retour à l'emploi notamment comme
indicateur deuxième principe qu'on peut
rappeler
essayer de faire en sorte que chaque
euro engagé soit un euro utile des choix
doivent être fait et tous les choix ne
sont pas consensuels c'est vrai mais
c'est le prix je crois de l'efficacité
que nous recherchons à cet égard je
pense aux maisons de l'emploi
leur vocation première des maisons de
l'emploi en partie je parle de la
vocation première disparue avec la
création de Pôle emploi
dès 2013 nous avons interrogé leur
plus-value et confirmer en 2014 le
recentrage de leur mission dans le
contexte sérieux budgétaire qui
caractérise la loi de finance 2015 je
dois donc être en la matière équilibrée
juste je propose donc de reconduire et
c'est ce qui est inscrit au niveau de
l'an dernier les crédits de
fonctionnement des maisons de l'emploi à
savoir 26 millions d'euros mais je
refuse je rejette tout financement
spécifique complémentaire et j'ai pris
l'engagement à l'Assemblée je le
renouvelle devant vous je m'engage à ce
que les maisons de l'emploi est accès au
crédit qu'on appelle des crédits de
droits communs qui sont les crédits
d'accompagnement des mutations
économiques qui s'élèvent en crédit de
paiement à 40 millions d'euros pour
l'année lorsqu'elles ont un projet à
fort potentiel de
plus-value dans un contexte de chômage
de masse et d'allongement de la durée
passée au chômage malheureusement
l'urgence implique que les efforts
soient concentrés en vue d'offrir le
plus rapidement possible une solution
d'emploi ou d'activités ou de formation
et d'éviter l'éloignement durable du
travail du marché du travail des mesures
de saines gestion ou sont proposées par
ailleurs dans ce projet de budget la
mobilisation des réserves de
l'association qui gère les fonds pour
l'insertion professionnelle des
personnes handicapées à gifip et celle
du Fonds d'insertion de personnes
handicapées dans la fonction publique
elle mobilise des réserves dormantes
sans porter atteinte au moyen des uns et
des autres ou plutôt des unes et les
autres et cela représente deux fois 29
millions d'euros pour ce qui concerne le
fonds d'insertion des personnes
handicapées en fonction publique
j'indique par exemple que les fonds qui
restent à disposition téléphone
trésorerie s'élève à 394 millions
d'euros donc ça n'affecte pas la
politique de l'emploi des personnes
handicapées dont les moyens vous le
savez ont été fortement augmentés depuis
2012 de plus de 20 % et qui vont être
encore accrus puisque j'ai
répondu favorablement à un amendement
qui était présenté à l'Assemblée
nationale pour la création de 500 aides
au poste dans les entreprises adaptées
pour un coup de 7 millions d'euros je
rappelle que les entreprises adaptées
avaient eu du mal à consommer les postes
qu'il leur avait été proposé lors des
derniers budgets et que nous avons
ajusté cela en fonction de leur demande
troisième et dernier principe concentrez
les forces sur les priorités alors un
effort massif mais ça tout le monde le
en conscient en équation il faut le
faire pour la jeunesse avec la garantie
jeune et l'émission locale la garantie
jeune et un objectif qui est donné qui
est fixé
jeunes dès 2015
160 millions d'euros c'est plus 100
millions d'euros par rapport à 2014 dont
30 millions d'euros de crédit européens
un accompagnement de ceux qui sont au
bord du décrochage ou pas à mon avis qui
ont déjà décroché mais aussi une petite
allocation qui leur permet de pouvoir
suivre des périodes de stage d'immersion
en entreprise
c'est une la France a été la première à
mettre en oeuvre la garantie jeune et
donc il y a des financements spécifiques
européens pour cela ça s'adresse à des
jeunes qui sont ce qu'on appelle les
nids c'est à dire qui sont sans emploi
sans formation et sans stage au moment
de leur demande l'expérimentation de
cette garantie jeune est en cours depuis
sur 10 territoires depuis un an très
exactement enfin depuis novembre de
l'année dernière et elle va être élargie
à 10 nouveaux territoires au 1er janvier
2015 et j'ai lancé un nouvel appel à
projet au cours du mois de novembre il
sera il sera répandu pour je crois 20
territoires nouveaux voilà tout ça pour
arriver à ces fameux 50 000 je dois
rappeler qu'il y a aujourd'hui 6000
jeunes qui sont garantie jeunes j'ai eu
l'occasion de les rencontrer mais si
j'ai des questions sur ce sujet je
pourrais y répondre l'émission locale je
le rappelle sont essentiels pour
l'accompagnement des jeunes de 16 à 25
ans
188,8 millions d'euros au titre de la
subvention principale de l'État qui
avait été accrue de 10 millions d'euros
en 2014 et
269 millions d'euros au total en
incluant les crédits d'accompagnement de
la garantie jeune il y a des crédits
d'accompagnement pour la garantie jeunes
et des emplois d'avenir qui ont été
eux-mêmes majorées de 15 millions
d'euros à l'Assemblée nationale en
matière d'emploi des jeunes il y a pas
beaucoup d'endroits où on peut dire cela
on a contenu le chômage des jeunes même
légèrement reculé en un an l'objectif
qui avait été fixé de 150000 en peu
d'avenir a été atteint l'enveloppe de
50000 nouveaux emplois d'avenir prévu
pour 2015 a été porté par les députés à
65000 cela implique un effort de en
autorisation d'engagement de 1,7
milliards d'euros jusqu'à présent un
milliard 3 en crédit de paiement en 2015
après la lecture à l'Assemblée nationale
les emplois aidés mais ça les
gouvernements qui sont succédés ils font
appel et nous y faisons appel aussi il
prépare à l'emploi c'est un outil de la
politique de l'emploi et on peut et
c'est ce que nous avons fait en
améliorer en améliorer bien sûr la
qualité et le ciblage il y a une réelle
plus-value des contrats aidés pas
seulement lutter contre le chômage mais
aussi d'utilité sociale et de
préparation à
de garder un contact avec le monde du
travail par un emploi les députés ont
souhaité stabiliser les forces
financiers au niveau 2014 à hauteur de
3,2 milliards d'euros avec je donne les
grandes masses 300 000 contrats
contre 270 000 dans le PLF que j'avais
présenté donc avec une augmentation de
30 000 pour un montant de le total bien
sûr de 1,6 milliards d'euros et puis 80
000 contrats marchands c'était attendu
je le sais soit le double de 2014 car
les résultats des Cie sont très positifs
ils sont concentrés prioritairement sur
les seniors sur nous sommes en train d'y
travailler avec les partenaires sociaux
les demandeurs d'emploi de longue durée
et les chômeurs d'emploi de longue durée
et les travailleurs handicapés
le troisième point l'apprentissage c'est
un sujet très important
qui n'est pas un sujet que financier je
parlais bien sûr finance mais qui n'est
pas un sujet que financier qui est aussi
un sujet dont on devrait remplir les
têtes de l'ensemble des Français pour
leur dire que c'est une voix
d'excellence et non pas une voix de par
défaut comme bien souvent je l'entends
dire ici ou là et donc une mobilisation
qui se fait la nouvelle aide destinée
aux entreprises stabilisera cette
fois-ci les aides pour le recrutement
d'un ou de plusieurs apprentis bien
évidemment supplémentaires elle est
introduite dans la loi de finances par
le gouvernement donc je le rappelle
c'est un montant de 1000 euros pour
toutes les entreprises de moins de 250
salariés pour les contrats signer à
compter du 1er juillet 2014 donc de
manière presque rétroactive en général
quand on dirait trop actif c'est pour
pénaliser là c'est pour encourager j'ai
lu une chose d'importation sur ça et
donc les entreprises de moins de 250 et
puis évidemment pour celle de moins de
11 salariés qui avaient déjà une prime
2000 c'est sa double la prime mais ça la
porte à 2000 euros et on en reste là et
on ne bouge plus et on arrête de faire
des allers-retours qui déstabilisent
assez profondément qui ont des stabilisé
le l'ensemble du dispositif même si on
constatera d'ailleurs que dans les
entreprises de moins de 11 salariés
c'est là où il y a eu le plus fort recul
peut-être lié à l'activité enfin on
pourra y revenir il faut faire des
efforts sur ce secteur la réforme du
financement de l'apprentissage entre RA
d'ailleurs en vigueur au 1er janvier et
là permis de dégager
150 millions de ressources
supplémentaires d'ici 2017 à destination
des centres de formation d'apprentis
certains en ont vraiment vraiment besoin
j'en ai visité quelques-uns qui sont pas
à l'honneur de notre République pour
dire les choses plus clairement ils sont
pas le même qualité accueillir certains
jeunes apprentis dans ces conditions-là
n'est pas une manière de valoriser
l'apprentissage et donc il va falloir
consacrer des ressources là il s'agit
d'investissement sur les CFA et puis
dans les régions c'est une très fort
maintenant elle va permettre aux régions
de consolider leur ressources elle va
même leur garantir à terme j'en suis
persuadé une dynamique de recettes
puisque celle-ci seront indexées sur la
masse salariale ainsi de 2014 à 2015 la
croissance des ressources de régions
sera de 65 millions d'euros pour le
développement de l'apprentissage or
compensation qui sera intégrale bien
évidemment compensation des primes
d'apprentissage le gouvernement compense
par ailleurs ces primes par
l'affectation des crédits budgétaires
pour les nouvelles primes mais surtout
par des recettes fiscales TICPE comme la
prévue l'article 13 projet de loi de
finances 2015 qui a affecté à ce titre
aux régions et aux régions au sol de 155
millions d'euros voilà j'ai essayé
d'aller à l'essentiel je suis le
président il faut bien mesurer mais je
ne me plains pas en faisant cela que ces
efforts sont faits dans un contexte
contraint ils sont à la hauteur je le
crois de l'enjeu en tous les cas même si
j'ai des propos qui sont des fois qui
portent qui portent parce que c'est un
constat c'est un budget de mobilisation
j'y crois de préparation de l'avenir et
notamment si j'ai des questions sur ce
sujet je pourrais y répondre les
politiques de l'emploi elles sont
efficaces pour préparer l'emploi de
demain pour celles et ceux qui profitent
en même temps des formations
merci monsieur le ministre monsieur le
rapporteur c'est à vous de poser
quelques questions
et merci monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre je crois que notre échange
par bien parce que nous partons d'un
constat partagé soyons honnêtes nous
sommes en échec c'est votre déclaration
dans un entretien accordé au journal de
parisien le 25 octobre dernier d'où
notre première question quelles
conséquence concrètes en tirez-vous pour
la mission travail et emploi du PLF 2015
la deuxième question concerne la dette
de lunédique qui devrait s'élever à 24,9
milliards d'euros en 2015 ce niveau est
bien entendu préoccupant et ne va pas
être sensiblement amélioré par la
nouvelle convention assurance chômage
qui ne permet que des économies nettes
annuelles de l'ordre de 450 millions
d'euros par rapport à l'ancienne
convention la commission des finances du
Sénat c'est d'ailleurs inquiétée de
cette situation lors de l'examen de
projet de loi de programmation des
finances publiques pour les années 2014
à 2019 et souhaite mieux informer le
Parlement article 27 quel message
souhaite faire passer le gouvernement
aux partenaires sociaux chargé de
négocier la prochaine convention
les contrats de génération qui sont des
seuls contrats qui aujourd'hui pour nous
ne sont pas à la hauteur des promesses
et des espoirs du gouvernement
l'étude d'impact annexé au projet de loi
créant le contrat du génération
indiquait nous pouvons espérer un volume
manuel d'embauche de jeunes en CDI
bénéficiaire de l'aide de 500
000 sur les 5 ans soit une moyenne de
1000 par an or selon les informations
fournies par vos services en compte au
31 mai 2014 seulement
21370 contrats de génération et vous
tablez pour 2015 sur la conclusion de
20000 nouveaux contrats soit un
cinquième des objectifs initiaux la
question est donc dans cette logique
allez-vous demander aux partenaires
sociaux de revoir leur copie et modifier
leur accord national interprofessionnel
pour faire du contrat de génération une
arme de lutte massive contre le chômage
c'est bien ce qu'il y avait été déclaré
au départ ou bien ce dispositif est-il
condamné à devenir un outil secondaire
dans votre panoplie pour lutter contre
le chômage et ne servir que de variables
d'ajustement chaque année lors de
l'examen budgétaire
les emplois d'avenir vous l'avez
d'ailleurs largement évoqué en nombre
l'objectif est atteint mais où le bât
blesse c'est que seulement 43% des
jeunes entrés en emploi d'avenir avant
juin 2013 en réaliser au moins une
formation qui peut être quelques heures
de formation qui est pas forcément une
formation complète comment comptez-vous
répondre à ces deux faiblesses des
emplois d'avenir en outre comment
expliquer vous le taux de rupture des
emplois d'avenir de 27,5 en 2013 si l'on
en croit le bleu budgétaire appelle le
il y a également vous en avez fait part
sur les contrats qui sont des contrats
qui sont aussi en augmentation puisque
vous les passez les CIA de 50000 à 80000
donc je crois que c'est une bonne chose
d'augmenter le nombre mais suite à
l'adoption de l'amendement de Monsieur
Leroux l'a dit à l'Assemblée nationale
laisser il y aura quatre fois plus que
les Cie où allez-vous trouver vous avez
répondu à mon avis partiellement à cette
question dans votre introduction les 175
millions d'euros de crédit de paiement
qui découlent de l'adoption de
l'amendement de Monsieur Leroux faudra
bien les trouver il ne faudrait-il pas
poursuivre le rééquilibrage initié par
le gouvernement et donner plus de poids
au contrat aidé dans le secteur
concurrentiel puisque c'est là où on
voit qu'il y a une production efficace
plutôt que dans le secteur non marchand
évidemment pour nous tout se base sur un
budget sur des optimistes un optimisme
peut-être un petit peu trop élevé par
rapport à la situation globale et puis
vous en avez parlé aussi pour nous les
assises de l'apprentissage témoignent
d'une prise de conscience quand même
très tardive du gouvernement des
difficultés que traversent cette voie
d'alternance qui pour nous est une piste
essentielle pour l'avenir avec une chute
des contrats d'apprentissage depuis 2013
comment allez-vous financer concrètement
l'enveloppe de 60 millions d'euros pour
nouvelle prime de l'apprentissage de
1000 euros introduite après l'article 52
donc là aussi vous avez commencé à
évoquer le sujet mais je crois qu'il
faudrait nous apporter un peu plus de
précision pensez-vous pas nécessaire de
mettre en place avec les régions un
pilotage national de l'apprentissage
parce qu'on se rend compte en France que
suivant les régions la problématique de
l'apprentissage est complètement traité
différemment des régions en quelque
sorte en une politique
incitative plus forte et pour nous c'est
aussi une priorité donc je crois qu'il
faut aussi à mon sens peut-être qu'il y
a un lien avec l'éducation nationale
parce que aujourd'hui la difficulté de
l'apprentissage a-t-il personnel peut
vous en parler parce que j'avais une
entreprise artisanale de taille de
pierre et de sculpture donc on a une
forte culture de formation d'apprenti et
je peux vous dire que là il y a quand
même à mon sens
peut-être une nouvelle ligne politique
inventée et puis je terminerai par un
problème qui est certes par la problème
globale du monde du travail parce que je
voudrais quand même vous parler compte
tenu du bruit que cela fait au niveau
national
les intermittents du spectacle
il faut en parler quand même l'état
décidé de prendre en charge de différé
des indemnisations pour les
intermittents du spectacle institué par
cette nouvelle convention assurance
chômage à travers le décret du 13
octobre 2014 une Edith estime que ce
différet représente 70 millions en 2015
puis 100 millions d'euros en année
pleine comment se traduit concrètement
cette prise en charge de l'État dans le
PLF 2015 j'en ai terminé avec les
questions préliminaires voilà Monsieur
ministre je vous laisse répondre aux
questions du rapporteur
merci
monsieur le Président j'ai essayé de
répondre le plus précisément possible
monsieur le monsieur le rapporteur
madame monsieur c'est notre sénateur
j'ai fait un constat mais le constat que
je fais il n'est pas lié à ce
gouvernement je voudrais le dire ici
l'échec il est collectif et il vient de
loin je rappelle chaque fois cela mais
en 40 ans la richesse notre pays était
métier par deux notre pays quant à moi
ce qu'on croit pas il s'enrichit et le
PIB a été multiplié par deux la
production intérieure brute et le
suivant l'indicateur que l'on prend le
taux de chômage a été multiplié par 3 il
était à peine de 3% de 2,9% en 1975 il
atteint aujourd'hui 9,7 et peut-être
demain d'ici la fin de l'année 9,8
et non pas 11% comme le dit Monsieur
Gattaz mais au niveau des comparaisons
internationales c'est 9,7% au jour
d'aujourd'hui France métropolitaine il a
eu un pic de 10,6 ou 10,7 %
sous l'homme qui visiblement est un des
préférés des français en ce moment à la
Juppé comme quoi vous voyez tout est
permis pour tout le monde et donc on
voit qu'il y a une évolution du taux
donc
si je prenais en compte les inscrits
pour le coup à Pôle Emploi de catégorie
A puisque on est quand même un des rares
pays à considérer comme chômeur
ceux qui ont travaillé plus 78 heures
dans le mois en Allemagne ça fait
longtemps que s'il travaille quelques
heures dans le mois qui précède ils ne
sont pas comptabilisés comme chômeur
chez nous plus de 78 heures considéré
comme chômeur c'est quand même assez
curieux le temps partiel n'est pas
forcément même il est subi une marque de
chômage au sens strict international
donc on a 3 millions 400 000 chômeurs
aujourd'hui il y en avait 600 000 580
000 en 1975 donc et
hormis n'y voyait aucune
aucune agression politique mais hormis
la période
2000-2001
le chômage monte et il avait baissé
jusqu'en 2008 nouvelle crise nouvelle
crise des nouvelles hausses continues
qu'on a du mal c'est vrai et donc voilà
c'est c'est ce constat que j'ai voulu
faire parce que je crois que finalement
les Français sont beaucoup plus
conscients de la réalité des choses que
souvent leur dirigeants donc je me suis
permis de le dire voilà donc je voulais
vous apporter cette réponse et je pense
que c'est vraiment un enjeu collectif on
a fait le choix dans notre pays
entreprise dirigeant tout le monde a
fait le choix du chômage c'est du
chômage de masse d'un choix qui a été
fait c'est le la volonté de préserver
ceux qui sont déjà en situation ça
s'appelle les insiders en anglais et ne
pas laisser rentrer ceux qui sont à
l'extérieur et donc et là ils
participent l'ensemble des partenaires
l'ensemble des partenaires voilà je sais
que c'est pas politiquement correct ce
que je dis là mais c'est quand même la
vérité je suis sûr que tout le monde le
sait mais on ne le dit pas toujours
voilà
la dette de lunédique bah elle est aussi
la conséquence de ce que je viens de
dire mais ce que je voudrais indiquer
c'est qu'on peut suivant ce qui va se
passer dans notre pays en termes de
croissance à moyen terme est soit très
pessimiste soit
optimiste car vous le savez monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames messieurs c'est
notre dessinateur vous le savez
cette c'est finance de lunédique sont
très sensibles aux évolutions du nombre
d'inscrits à Pôle emploi pour le coup
puisque vous avez soit la double peine
soit la double gratification moins
d'indemnisation à apporter et plus de
recettes de cotisations ou le contraire
ce qui est ce qui se passe en ce moment
c'est-à-dire plus d'indemnisations et
moins de et moins de cotisants on a des
taux de cotisation de notre pays qui
sont relativement élevés il faut le dire
parce que on me dit souvent il y a un
taux notre système est protecteur il
faut le dire il est plutôt protecteur et
c'est plutôt bien moi j'ai des choses
comme je le pense il est même on peut
dire très protecteur je dis pas trop
protecteur je dis très protecteur et
donc puisque suivant les périodes
travaillées on peut être indemnisés deux
ans ou trois ans si plus de il y en a
plus de 50 ans et donc je mets ça en
regard de deux choses si vous me le le
premier le taux de cotisation des
salariés eux-mêmes les cotisations à
l'assurance chômage pour les salaires
pour les salariés eux-mêmes cotisations
salariales s'élèvent à 2,4% du salaire
brut puisqu'il représente quand même en
fin d'année si on regarde bien plus de
50 % d'un salaire net de cotisation donc
ils participent quand même à ce régime
et alors les employeurs eux c'est 4% et
donc on voit bien qu'il y a des taux de
cotisations qui permettent de rétablir
assez rapidement les comptes si ça
s'améliore c'est arrivé je peux me
tromper ne m'en voulez pas je ne sais
plus si c'est en 2005 ou un 2006 mais il
y a eu une baisse du chômage assez
importante et d'un coup en fait
d'inscrire à Pôle emploi des choses
comme ça de demandeur d'emploi et d'un
coup il y a eu 5 milliards
d'améliorations des comptes de lunédique
en une seule année donc on voit bien que
on peut avoir un gap important
demain
l'Union européenne se mettait à investir
un peu plus elle nous aidait en la
matière mais enfin ça c'est un autre
sujet le déficit les partenaires sociaux
ont quand même fait des efforts
j'aurai l'occasion d'y revenir d'une
autre manière à la fin la question sur
les intermittents mais les partenaires
sociaux à la demande du gouvernement ont
fait des efforts le déficit était de 4
milliards 100 je crois en 2013 à la fin
de l'année il sera entre 3 milliards 7
et 3 milliards 8 c'est quelques 400
millions d'euros et
de d'amélioration que qui ont été
escomptés et c'est au total je crois que
je ne dise pas de bêtises près de 800
millions d'euros qui sont escomptés
d'économies par rapport à ce qui était
prévu à travers la réforme enfin ce qui
a été adopté par les partenaires sociaux
au mois de mars 2014
voilà ce que je peux vous dire dessus
sur ce point j'ajouterai dans les
éléments de comparaison parce qu'il faut
toujours avoir ça en tête que je disais
le système français est très protecteur
le taux de taux de pauvreté quand même
un élément très important le taux de
pauvreté des chômeurs français et de
l'ordre de 37 à 38%. disons 38%. il n'a
pas évolué ce qui monte le caractère
protecteur du système d'indemnisation du
chômage en Allemagne où ont été créés 7
millions et demi de mini Jobs qui coûte
453 euros aux employeurs le
taux de pauvreté des chômeurs allemands
qui sont moins nombreux au sens du BIT
que les nôtres a été effacé de 38%, il
était identique au nôtre avant la
réforme à 64% aujourd'hui et donc 63%
peut-être et donc on voit que
suivant que le régime est protecteur ou
pas en même temps les effets c'est bien
sûr il est protecteur il protège de la
pauvreté il protège moins plus ou moins
de la pauvreté c'était quelques éléments
que je souhaitais vous apporter
je continue les contrats de génération
oui c'est vrai il produit pas les effets
que nous aurions pu en attendre d'ici la
fin de l'année il y aura 35000 demandes
qui auront été au total enregistré 15000
2013 20 000 2014
donc je le redis quand même ça
correspond c'est vrai que c'est pas ça
pas l'effet massif que qu'on aurait pu
en attendre mais ça correspond quand
même à 70 000 je suis bien obligé de
constater comme ça 70000 personnes 35000
maintenus dans leur emploi qui n'ont pas
perdu leur emploi et 35000 qui rentrent
des jeunes avec des seniors pour 2015
c'est 40000 nouvelles demandes qui sont
prévues pourquoi parce qu'on a élargi le
les emplois d'avenir c'est peut-être un
des points de désaccord que nous pouvons
avoir monsieur le rapporteur parce que
j'ai vu je le dis dans dans un journal
des commentaires sur exemple à l'avenir
qui ne correspondent absolument pas à
l'étude que la DARES qui a un organisme
indépendant qui fait des études
statistiques vient de fournir et que je
pourrais vous faire passer une étude
assez complète qui a été fait même très
complète qui a été faite par la Dares
elle montre que les emplois d'avenir
sont bien une priorité une réponse à la
priorité qui est donnée à l'insertion du
rap des jeunes
83 alors ça dépend 82 ou 83% vous ne
m'en voudrez pas qui ont signé un emploi
d'avenir ne sont pas titulaires du
baccalauréat dont 40% n'avaient n'ont
aucun diplôme aucun diplôme donc ça
c'est sur une année puisqu'on peut avoir
le bilan d'une année disons sur l'année
36% des emplois d'avenir ont été signés
par des jeunes qui résident soit dans
une juge zone urbaine sensible soit en
zone de revitalisation rurale ou en
outre-mer ou c'est un peu plus compliqué
pour d'autres d'autres raisons locales
sur lequel je pourrais revenir si vous
avez des questions sur ce sujet et puis
66% des emplois d'avenir sont signés
dans le secteur marchand sont des CDI et
56% de l'ensemble à venir sont signés
pour une durée d'au moins trois ans donc
c'est quelque chose qui est installé
vraiment les jeunes dans l'emploi
j'ajoute et là c'est ça que je voulais
vous dire qu'il y a une différence parce
que il y a très faible taux de rupture
de ces contrats très faible taux de
l'ordre 9% à 6 mois tout ça par rapport
au contrat classique ce qui
atteste de la qualité de
l'accompagnement et puis
100% des conventions alors on pourrait
parler de la nature de la convention on
en parlera mais 100% des conventions
signées prévoit au moins une action de
formation je suis effectivement
régulièrement interrogé sur le chiffre
également donné dans l'étude de 43 % des
jeunes entrées en appel à l'avenir qui
ont subi qui ont suivi par l'empathie
mais suivi une formation au bout d'un an
ce chiffre peut sembler décevant c'est
vrai au regard de l'objectif mais il
faut regarder cela par rapport à durée
des contrats ils peuvent atteindre trois
ans et 56% des contrats de moins de 3
ans ont vu une formation
offerte à ces jeunes voilà ce que je
voulais vous dire pour une fois on peut
le dire le taux de chômage des jeunes ah
bah c'est de 1,2%
en un an j'espère que ça va durer
j'espère que ça va durer les questions
posées aussi sur les contrats aidés
c'est bien cela oui je prends dans
l'ordre les contrats aidés donc
3 milliards d'euros de crédit de
paiement pour les emplois aidés c'est à
peu près je l'avais dit tout à l'heure
dans mon introduction première de
l'année d'avant donc ça peut préparer
les volumes de prescription
prévu en 2015 et
445000 si on prend en compte après
première lecture à l'Assemblée nationale
soit une légère augmentation par rapport
à 2014 plus de 15000 plus 15000 pardon
plus 15000 donc on passe de 430 à 445 je
rappelle qu'il y a eu des pics dans
notre histoire de contrats aidé
il y a eu une période à la fin des
années
90 où il y avait 560000 555
000 contrats aider voilà donc on est
encore loin de mais on fait avec les
moyens dont on dispose je préfère en
avoir plus je vais vous le cache pas
mais c'est comme ça
la programmation elle est attendue vous
en avez fait vous avez fait référence
monsieur rapporteur la programmation de
contrat marchand augmente oui c'est je
pense que c'est une bonne piste moi
aussi je suis à sensible puisqu'on passe
de 40 000 à 80 000 ça c'est bien je
pense peut-être on ira encore plus loin
si on peut en cours d'année on ajustera
s'il le faut l'enveloppe des contrats et
des non marchands elle est de 300 000 et
grâce à l'apport des députés puisque
elle était 270 000 elle était portée à
300000 et elle a atteint 340 000 en
réalité en 2014 donc il faut savoir ça
quant aux emplois d'avenir elle augmente
je l'ai dit donc je vais pas y revenir
de 65000 contre 50000 la qualité des
contrats aidés est une préoccupation
constante
je voudrais le rappeler puisque ça avait
été noté dans j'avais participé dans ce
qu'on appelait à l'époque le Grenelle de
l'insertion qui avait été lancé en 2008
la durée des CAE c'était un élément
important de lutte contre
le fait de retomber dans la précarité ne
lutte contre la précarité il a augmenté
de manière importante en 2012 c'était
6,6 mois sur l'ensemble du secteur non
marchand or assez lié chantier
d'insertion et aujourd'hui enfin
septembre et je vérifie chaque mois avec
les préfets elle est de 11,3 mois donc
près d'un an on peut dire de durée donc
ça c'est important le ciblage est fait
sur le public les plus fragiles et en
termes d'accompagnement je l'ai dit il y
a des formations qui sont proposées et
qui sont qualifiantes pour certaines
l'apprentissage vous avez raison de le
rappeler c'est vrai que ça devrait être
une c'est une grande cause nationale et
c'est un des moyens non seulement de
lutter contre le chômage mais si c'était
que ça ça serait pas suffisant c'est
aussi à des moyens de préparer l'avenir
souvent pour les entreprises à moyen de
préparer la transmission notre prise
très importante le secteur
d'apprentissage le secteur
d'apprentissage dans l'artisanat
notamment donc j'ai dit ce qu'il en
était
je suis en train de chercher mes petites
notes puisque je sais que vous m'avez
demandé est-ce qu'il faudrait un
pilotage national oui c'est on essaie de
le faire mais c'est des centralisé
maintenant au niveau des régions donc il
faut vraiment suivre au niveau des
régions et là je compte sur les les
parlementaires pour le faire parce que
transfert des crédits mais après il faut
voir si ils sont bien utilisés
strictement à cela donc j'ai mobilisé
les présidents de région pour pour ce
faire il y aura une augmentation
importante en 2015 des moyens 65
millions d'euros pour les régions donc
il faudra vérifier l'utilisation et de
suivre il y a quand même des problèmes
nationaux vous avez raison qui sont
posés il y a des des
apprentissages des métiers qui se font à
travers une transversalité nationale et
c'est pas possible autrement donc il
faut garder un œil sur une sorte de
pilotage national le montant je l'ai pas
dit tout à l'heure pour j'avais oublié
j'avais noté vous m'avez demandé comment
financera les emplois aidés à hauteur de
supplémentaires à hauteur de 175
millions d'euros et les
primes d'apprentissage à hauteur de 60
millions d'euros
et bien à la fin de la discussion
budgétaire par solidarité ministérielle
on peut dire cela mes collègues
pourraient dire par taxation
et participeront à cet effort voilà
comment ça se ça se fera et donc pas par
une
pas par des taxes supplémentaires par
par des économies entre entre nous voilà
ensuite
ensuite il y a une question sur les les
intermittents oui les intermittents
alors les intermittents
pourquoi je l'évoquais tout à l'heure
parce que finalement on demande aux
partenaires sociaux de gérer l'assurance
chômage à travers une édique ils le font
il faut un effort il faut un accord et
puis
voilà TIPA que
et bien ça recommence je dis ça parce
que c'est problème récurrent
pour faire des économies ils étaient
appelés à faire des économies eux-mêmes
le régime qui
concerne les
articles je sais plus que quels articles
c'est mais bon je vais retrouver ça va
me revenir
c'est les annexes 7 et 9 c'est les
annexes 7 et 9 je crois
donc les annexes 7 et 9 les concernent
les techniciens et les autres les
artistes 8 et 10 je l'ai perdu
pourquoi je suis parti sur scène
merci
bon c'est pas c'est pas grave il faut
pas faire de
j'essaie de faire ça de mémoire des fois
ça voilà
ça arrive donc les années futéistes donc
elles avaient prévu les partenaires
sociaux est prévu indifférent différé
qui a été dans un premier temps retouché
parce qu'il s'était un peu trompé on va
dire des choses comme ça dans le calcul
et c'était finalement pas ceux qui
avaient le plus d'indemnisations qui
étaient le plus différé donc ils ont
refait les calculs mais la machine était
partie et donc le mouvement a été lancé
sur ce et pour
arrêter ce mouvement qui porte atteinte
incontestablement malgré les abus qu'on
connaît il y a des abus dedans on sait
bien elle vient souvent de l'entreprise
d'ailleurs du spectacle l'audiovisuel
qui n'ont pas grand chose à voir avec
formellement le métier d'intermittent ou
le statut de l'intermittent plus
exactement et donc du spectacle et donc
le différé a été annulé pour le moment
donc il y a plus de différé le régime
hanté est revenu et donc et c'est une
mission qui a été confiée à un député
Jean Patrick Gilles avec
Jean-Denis cambrexcell et Madame
Archambault et ils ont jusqu'à la fin de
l'année pour nous faire des propositions
mais pour le moment nous avons sorti la
partie
intermittente c'est-à-dire les annexes
et 10 de l'accord de l'unédique et nous
sommes revenus à la situation antérieure
avec la prise en compte
par le budget en l'occurrence je crains
que ce soit le nôtre le mien de de ces
fameuses annexes 8 et 10 voilà monsieur
oui mais monsieur le ministre si vous me
permettez je voudrais vous demander
quelques compléments notamment sur les
emplois aidés en tant qu'élu local et la
plupart d'entre nous ici sont ici du
milieu des élus locaux on se rend compte
que les contrats églés on va dire
globalement pose un problème c'est à la
sortie à la fin du contrat parce que si
dans les contrats d'avenir encore une
fois je vous le dis pour moi en tant que
nombre de jeunes engagés c'est une
réussite le milieu social c'est une
réussite mais ensuite
à partir du moment où dans ce type de
contrat à mon sens on n'a pas une
obligation suffisante de formation c'est
pas un contrat qui amène une
qualification comme on a vu dans
d'autres typologies de contrats
suffisante en sortie pour nous permettre
de donner des filières d'avenir comme on
a un parcours du logement on doit aussi
un parcours professionnel et plus on
part dans la vie plus c'est difficile et
à mon avis c'est un peu à ce niveau là
qu'il faudrait qu'on voit un peu
d'espoir au bout de ces contrats et ça
évidemment dans une situation économique
qui n'est pas bonne pas beaucoup de
poste à la sortie mais je crois qu'il
faudrait travailler dans le sens et
faire un effort particulier au niveau de
l'apprentissage vous l'avez bien dit en
ouverture vous vous héritez d'une
situation qui perdure en France depuis
de nombreuses années parce qu'on avait
d'un côté les blouses blanches et les
blouses grises et on a c'est un peu ce
qui intéresse l'éducation nationale
l'enseignement général et tout mais le
professionnel je me rends compte dans
mes fonctions que j'ai eu au conseil
général du Rhône et dans dans voulu
faire beaucoup de choses on a quand même
une difficulté quand ce qui concerne
l'apprentissage en France qui est pas
reconnu comme une cause nationale et une
filière que je qualifierais comme on
considère plutôt en Allemagne comme
préliminaire d'un système et intégrer
dans un système éducatif global alors
que là on a l'impression donc
l'apprentissage c'est considéré encore
dans notre pays c'est le premier le
regretté par une sous-formation alors je
peux vous en parler
facilement parce qu'en ce qui me
concerne je n'ai qu'un diplôme
d'enseignement professionnel ça m'a pas
empêché de faire mon chemin dans la vie
donc je crois qu'aujourd'hui il y a
aussi un problème que je qualifierais
permettez-moi de le dire culturel qui
pénalise l'apprentissage en France et un
système qui fasse un lien que des
entreprises et qui
qui forment des apprentis n'est pas
qu'une reconnaissance on va dire qu'une
prime financière mais il y a une un peu
une reconnaissance du rôle social que
font ces entreprises dans le rôle
d'accompagnement et pas les services de
l'éducation nationale au lieu de
considérer que c'est plutôt un peu d'un
côté une forme d'Ayatollah de
l'éducation nationale en disant ben oui
mais là la formation professionnelle bon
c'est une deuxième c'est une couche
particulière de formation alors que
c'est une formation essentielle pour les
jeunes de banlieue vous savez moi j'ai
toujours été hostile en ce qui me
concerne et beaucoup d'élules sont comme
moi prendre des jeunes qui sont de toute
façon y arriveront les faire rentrer par
les petites portes dans des grandes
écoles et dire on a on a sorti 7 jeunes
d'une banlieue et on en a fait des As
dans leur dans leur domaine mais c'est
pas ça pour nous qui nous faut c'est une
évolution de masse de tous ces jeunes
qui a dans les banlieues qui sont dans
les quartiers difficiles et je pense que
la donc on est c'est l'apprentissage
pour seul je suis heureux à la fois de
vos propos mais j'aimerais que que les
propos qui sont tenus par les uns et les
autres soient concrétisés dans des
documents budgétaires et dans des
orientations politiques qui soient
appliquées voilà voilà le sentiment que
j'ai sur l'apprentissage et je crois que
les collègues qui veulent vous poser
maintenant quelques questions
oui oui ça fait oui
un mot monsieur le rapporteur je
voudrais effectivement il y a sur les
employés des je parle pas des emplois
d'avenir on en a parlé il y a deux types
de contrats et des différentes il y a
ceux qui sont les contrats marchands et
là on passe à 80 000 donc c'est 200
millions d'euros je vais l'utiliser je
vais les utiliser beaucoup pour le plan
senior car je pense que c'est très
important de permettre à des seniors ou
à des chômeurs de longue durée souvent
des seniors d'ailleurs malheureusement
de pouvoir reprendre pied dans
l'entreprise
découvert c'est ces contrats et donc on
va le faire on le fait aussi pour les
personnes
handicapées le taux alors deuxième
partie donc c'est vrai que vous avez
raison en plus c'est pour ça qu'on le
fait pour l'essayer dans le secteur dans
le secteur marchand taux d'intégration
dans l'emploi durable c'est 60%. alors
que pour les CAE c'est 30%. c'est tout à
fait juste et donc mais malgré tout
c'est une fonction sociale vous le savez
malgré tout sa prépa et c'est pour ça
qu'on a allongé la durée des des CAE
parce que plus on allonge la durée des
caeurs si on arrive à un an on pourra
pas aller plus loin c'est bien plus on a
des chances après que la personne qui
est en CAE dans le secteur non marchand
trouve un emploi et repris l'habitude de
l'emploi sur l'apprentissage je ne peux
que vous suivre et partager le sentiment
pour pour l'éducation nationale alors il
faut essayer d'en profiter maintenant
puisqu'il y a eu une table ronde lors de
la dernière grande conférence sociale
sur ce sujet avec l'Éducation nationale
quand on parle de l'apprentissage on
parle de l'alternance il parle de
l'alternance et ils vise les niveaux
supérieurs et on nous parle vous voyez
en alternance on a des jeunes qui ont
fait qui sont Masters très bien c'est
très bien pour l'image à condition qu'on
dise bien parce que c'est de
l'apprentissage et pas de l'alternance
parce qu'on commence à créer déjà une
petite séparation elle et le vrai
problème vous l'avez évoqué c'est quand
on a des niveaux qui sont des niveaux
bas au départ c'est et c'est là où on a
l'effet de masse d'ailleurs c'est pour
ce qui est niveau 5 et moins et là
effectivement pour dire la vérité ça se
bouscule pas non plus dans les
entreprises pour prendre des jeunes en
apprentissage et c'est un problème
culturel moi je partage cela ça va de
l'éducation nationale jusqu'à
l'entreprise en Allemagne prendre un
jeune en apprentissage
par l'idée que ben voilà c'est une voix
d'échec et c'est pas une voie de
réussite alors que ce sont des
professions dont on a besoin et qui vont
être rempli d'ailleurs par des
travailleurs détachés de plus en plus si
on y prend garde donc je partage ce
sentiment et on peut pas dire que la
fonction publique est donnée l'exemple
aussi parce que 700 je crois c'est ça à
peu près ça 700 jeunes en apprentissage
dans la fonction publique pour des tas
de raisons les freins notamment parce
qu'il y a pas de maître d'apprentissage
de tuteur etc etc donc on va lever je
voulais vous le dire j'ai pas eu le
temps de développer ça j'espère que je
réponds peut-être à une question à
l'avance on va lever les freins à
l'apprentissage j'en connais d'autres
que vous connaissez le fait que c'est
pour pour des entreprises en France avec
nos mentalité pour certaines entreprises
c'est c'est lourd à porter et puis des
jeunes ne peuvent pas trouver se trouver
en situation de travail effective il y a
ça j'ai pas de mettre en cause ou en
danger la sécurité de ces jeunes si vous
voyez ce que je veux dire mais on
devrait pouvoir quand on est jeune
monter sur un escabeau pour cueillir une
pomme par exemple donc ça serait
interdit aux jeunes de moins de 18 ans
mais ça serait autorisé aux personnes de
plus de 60 ans en général c'est
l'inverse normalement on a mis interdire
d'ailleurs à des personnes de plus de 60
ans de monter sur des escabots très
élevés voilà même si nous le
continuerons à le faire je parle pour
moi et donc
je me permettrai pas ce président donc
je partage tout à fait tout à fait votre
votre sentiment on va prendre je vais
présenter au Conseil d'orientation
au coq de la je pense dans le mois qui
vient un certain nombre de mesures qui
facilite la vie des chefs d'entreprise
qui prendront un jeune en apprentissage
et puis qui leur permettront de
mettre les jeunes en situation sans les
mettre en danger voilà c'est quand même
l'enjeu
bien mes chers collègues vous êtes neuf
inscrits à poser des questions et
Monsieur le Ministre doit nous quitter à
18h premier inscrit monsieur Cardou
l'ensemble a été largement développé et
une partie des réponses monsieur le
ministre vous les avez apporté dans
votre propos donc je vais affiner dans
deux domaines particuliers les emplois
aidés les emplois d'avenir vous êtes
convaincu vos propos l'ont souligné de
la pertinence de les aider dans le
secteur marchand avec un taux de sortie
en CDI de plus de 60% comme le dit le
rapport d'adresse compte 30% dans le
secteur public alors pourquoi dans ces
conditions-là annoncer 200 000 emplois
aidés à venir dans le secteur public et
que 80 000 dans le secteur marchand
quand quelque chose fonctionne bien et
débouche à 60% vers des emplois en CDI
pourquoi ne pas utiliser de manière
beaucoup plus importante alors qu'on
sait très bien que dans le secteur
public ça débouche sur une formation
tout à fait précaire et que ceux qui en
ont bénéficié se retrouvent en recherche
dans une grande majorité des cas après
ça c'est la première question la seconde
question en matière d'apprentissage je
ne reviens pas sur tout ce qui est dit
deal le manque de confiance qu'on entend
des entreprises après avoir d'abord
supprimé les 1000 euros et maintenant
les rétablir donc ça c'est un peu en
avant un panier et comme un peu
préjudiciable à la confiance que peuvent
avoir les entreprises mais ma question
elle sera très simple on nous l'avions
souligné dans le débat sur la formation
professionnelle l'État va transférer
l'ensemble de la compétence
apprentissage aux régions pensez-vous
que la réforme territoriale en cours
avec la taille des régions sur
lesquelles nous avons travaillé même si
nous les avons un peu réduite dans le
débat au Sénat et la bonne dose et le
bon format pour avoir une politique de
proximité en matière d'apprentissage moi
j'avoue que j'en doute mais j'aimerais
avoir votre éclaircissement sur cette
chose là et précisément si vous estimez
que ce n'est pas la bonne dose c'est pas
le bon format pour avoir une politique
de proximité que comptez-vous proposer
pour que l'État reprenne un peu la main
de manière à redévelopper une politique
de proximité en matière d'apprentissage
oui monsieur le ministre une question
sur un sujet que vous avez abordé et sur
lequel je sais que vous êtes très très
passionné ça y est Maison de l'Emploi je
dirais ils ont de l'emploi et de la
formation et de la formation je tiens
beaucoup vous savez que il y a une
maison de la formation à Cherbourg
depuis 1991 et je sais que vous étiez
pilote en matière aussi oui donc les
crédits cette année sont décrédits 26
millions reportés comme l'année dernière
l'an passé il y avait donc 10 millions
versets sous forme d'appel à projet et
les maisons de l'emploi c'est vrai qu'on
des résultats très contrastés mais je
veux dire que ce sont celles qui sont
les plus performantes peut-être qu'ils
sont les plus inquiets parce qu'elles
ont besoin de lisibilité parce qu'ils
ont besoin de s'investir en moyen terme
et nous dans les territoires ce sont des
lieux extraordinaires de travail et de
projection vers l'avenir entre les
entreprises les élus locaux les forces
syndicales il y a les enseignants il y a
un travail en commun et quand on veut
comment dire réorienter un certain
ambassade d'emploi elles sont à fait
indispensables donc pourriez-vous nous
dire comment vous envisagez de pouvoir
continuer à les aider à la hauteur
nécessaire comment c'est 40 millions de
crédits communs seront seront alloués
parce qu'elles craignent beaucoup d'être
mise en concurrence celles qui sont
performantes avec des des projets qui
finalement seront peut-être pas aussi
performants qu'il le faudrait et se
trouver de privé de de crédit voilà je
vais pas aller plus loin il y a une
inquiétude et je profite de la
circonstance pour vous demander
d'essayer de lever ces inquiétudes
monsieur le ministre avant qu'on nous
ayons aussi
oui monsieur le ministre votre budget
est en baisse et pourtant l'emploi la
formation professionnelle
l'apprentissage aurait dû être
privilégié dans un budget d'enseignement
difficiles compte tenu effectivement de
la dégradation de l'emploi on aurait pu
espérer un budget plus volontariste vous
poursuivez votre politique des contrats
aidé dans cette période où la croissance
n'est pas suffisante et dans un contexte
économique difficile on peut pas on ne
peut pas être opposé à l'augmentation
des contrats toutefois monsieur le
ministre les emplois aidés et vous le
savez aussi ils ne sont pas la seule
réponse adaptée pour stopper la
dégradation de l'emploi d'ailleurs les
résultats de cette politique ne sont pas
toujours au rendez-vous parce qu'on
constate depuis le début septembre une
légère reprise du chômage chez les
jeunes je vous poserai deux questions
monsieur le ministre la première c'est
quelle solution proposez-vous pour les
seniors vous l'avez évoqué tout à
l'heure le nombre de contrats de
professionnalisation pour les plus de 45
ans continue de diminuer les crédits
prévus permettent de financer seulement
5 contrat ce qui est notoirement
insuffisant par rapport effectivement à
la demande concernant les maisons de
l'emploi je reprends la réflexion de mon
collègue vous le savez ces structures
sont appréciées sur nos territoires en
tant qu'outil permettant de rassembler
l'ensemble des acteurs de l'emploi au
service du développement économique en
lien aussi avec les collectivités or les
maisons de l'emploi ne disposent plus de
moyens suffisants pour remplir leur
mission
certes vous nous avez confirmé que la
dotation était restée identique à celle
de 2014 mais comme ça a été dit à
l'instant l'année dernière un amendement
de 10 millions d'euros avait été rajouté
pour renforcer la ligne budgétaire à 36
millions à un moment où les maisons de
l'emploi ne peuvent plus bénéficier du
Fond Social Européen par le biais des
contrats de plan est à région il est
donc urgent que l'État continue à
soutenir ces structures pour leur
permettre de continuer à remplir leur
mission sur nos territoires c'est la
demande express monsieur le ministre des
responsables qui animent ces structures
et c'est aussi la demande des
collectivités qui les accompagnent et
pouvez-vous les rassurer par rapport
effectivement à cette nécessité
impérieuse d'aider nos maisons de
l'emploi mais même procacia
merci
je reprends tout de suite par rapport
aux maisons de l'emploi lorsque nous
avons créé Pôle Emploi fusion assez avec
lunédique
il y avait une étude qui avait été faite
et qui montrait qu'un bon nombre de ma
maison de l'emploi n'était pas très
efficace et la question que je voulais
vous poser je ne vais pas effectivement
dans le sens de mes collègues est-ce que
il y a on est avancé par rapport à ces
maisons de l'emploi qui pour certaines
non colle le titre et non pas
l'efficacité pour mieux se reconcentrer
sur celle qui fonctionne effectivement
et qui ne font pas un double emploi avec
justement Pôle emploi
sur la réforme de l'apprentissage je
suis heureuse de vous entendre tenir les
propos que vous tenez mais j'ai entendu
aussi que Monsieur Macron allait en
janvier proposer aussi des
simplifications sur l'apprentissage
est-ce qu'on pourrait pas avoir un seul
texte un peu de cohérence et pas comme
je l'ai dit hier des politiques de Stop
and Go qui font que c'est
incompréhensible et incompréhensible
pour particulièrement pour les TPE
et troisième et dernier point sur la
garantie jaune je n'ai jamais souscrit
au principe je le dis tout de suite de
cette garantie jeune vous l'avez dit
vous-même c'est une expérimentation sur
10 territoires alors d'abord qu'est-ce
que c'est qu'un territoire est-ce que
c'est un département est-ce que la
notion même de territoire
il y en a 6000 vous voulez aller à 50000
c'est un coût comment peut-on concevoir
de développer cette garantie jeune
c'est-à-dire grosso modo donner de
l'argent à ceux qui veulent plus aller à
l'école qui font pas de formation
et qui ont plus de contact avec leur
famille
alors qu'on en a pas fait
l'expérimentation ou alors on annonce
clairement que l'on fait un RSA jeune ce
qui n'avait pas voulu être fait
auparavant estimant que les jeunes ne
devaient pas commencer par
de la sistanat ou alors il y a une
véritable expérimentation mais comment
pouvez-vous annoncer qu'on passe de 10 à
50 sans avoir fait d'expérimentation
monsieur mouillé oui monsieur ministre
une intervention concernant notamment
vous avez évoqué la réforme des contrats
aidés dans le domaine non marchand et je
voudrais moi aborder le fonctionnement
des acides des ateliers chantiers
d'insertion puisque donc pour présider
ascendant de structure qui porte des
chantiers des ateliers on constate dans
le fonctionnement des grosses
difficultés notamment matière de
coordination difficulté en matière de
codation entre les différents financeurs
difficultés en matière également de
connaissances des montants des aides
puisque généralement les structures en
connaissance des volumes financiers une
fois que l'année était coulée donc
généralement en deuxième temps ce qui
entraîne des inquiétudes vis-à-vis des
porteurs de projets et également
troisième point concernant également les
délais de paiement notamment je pense
sur les aides d'État notamment du FSE
également fort européen ou en matière de
trésor on est sur décalage qui peuvent
être du 18 mois 2 ans et donc
aujourd'hui il y a une remise en cause
complète autour des autour des SCI donc
voilà donc si je voulais en tous les cas
vous alerter puisque parfois dans des
situations sociales très difficiles
c'est le dernier outil d'accompagnement
sans côté des expérimentations notamment
en matière de parrainage d'entreprise
puisqu'on se rend compte que les murs
résultats notamment dans les SCI sont
les structures qui ont mêlé à la fois le
parrainage d'entreprise une entreprise
qui paraît importer généralement de ces
différents ateliers donc ça c'était les
premières remarques une inquiétude sur
le fonctionnement et donc on a
aujourd'hui sur le territoire un certain
nombre d'Asie qui se posent des
questions d'arrêter à un clairement donc
cette mission là deuxième point
concernant également les maisons
d'emploi ça a été évoquées sur les
difficultés je voulais tout simplement
vous adapter sur le bon fonctionnement
des emplois on se rend compte
globalement que sur les territoires qui
étaient porteurs de comité de bassin
d'emploi quel est cette culture je
dirais de dialogue territorial qui qui
sont les je dirais les les grands
bénéficiaires de cette de cette réforme
donc je voulais certainement en revenir
sur l'évaluation je pense qu'il est on
ne peut pas on ne peut pas traiter
aujourd'hui les maisons-alpes niveau
national de la même façon je pense qu'il
y a des critères d'évaluation à mettre
en place et puis dernier point
concernant les contrats d'apprentissage
dans la fonction publique il est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui c'est un véritable gisier
qui pourrait être utilisé et que
simplement vous avez évoqué la notion de
simplifier je dirais l'accès pour les
collectivités la fonction publique mais
simplement avoir les mêmes droits que le
domaine privé notamment les systèmes
dérogatoire qui existe pour
l'apprentissage serait déjà un pas
essentiel pour pouvoir accueillir un
certain nombre d'apporter puisque là
c'est vraiment un jeu j'aurais été je
n'ai pas des chiffres en tête mais ça va
être difficile potentiel pour les jeunes
du territoire voilà madame devrait
oui merci monsieur le Président moi je
paie tout à fait d'accord avec tout ce
qui a été dit je trouve qu'on a fait
beaucoup déjà on a essayé beaucoup de
choses pour tout ce qui est fonction
publique on avait essayé les tucs
souvenez-vous là les travaux d'utilité
collective en 84 sous Fabius on avait
fait aussi les ces contrats solidarité
en 90 n'est-ce pas sous Michel Rocard
vous n'avez fait les emplois jeunes en
97 ou j'ose pas on a fait sous Nicolas
Sarkozy aussi bon on voit bien on voit
bien lui laissera on voit bien que dans
la fonction publique au moment où on
nous dit que les collectivités
territoriales et les collectivités
locales il faut diminuer le nombre de
diminuer les dépenses de personnel on
nous demande encore d'essayer de prendre
des contrats aidés des contrats d'avenir
des contrats de générations est-ce que
vous voulez bon donc ça pour moi je
pense que le gésier je suis pas
forcément sûr qu'il soit là le gésier il
est pour moi dans le secteur marchand
alors vous avez essayé effectivement les
contrats de génération
il y en a eu 33000 de signer en 18 mois
on a vu que ça fonctionnait absolument
pas vous nous dites que c'est parce
qu'il y a enfin ça ne fonctionne pas
très bien 33000 dans notre sur notre
territoire c'est quand même pas beaucoup
et puis ensuite les emplois d'avenir
alors les emplois d'avenir moi j'ai les
chiffres je sais pas s'ils sont exacts
ou pas mais je vois que en 2013 ça
coûtait 470 millions et en 2014 1,4
milliards
ne pensez-vous pas que c'est 1,4
milliards pourrait être utilisés
beaucoup plus justement dans la
formation professionnelle dans la
réforme de la formation professionnelle
et je suis tout à fait d'accord avec ce
que vient de dire ma collègue Catherine
procacia pourquoi ne pas coupler avec ce
que nous annonce les annonces que nous
fait Emmanuel Macron sur justement faire
une grande réforme de l'apprentissage
qu'on attend puisque
l'apprentissage a diminué je crois de 8%
l'année dernière de mémoire peut-être je
me trompe sur les 8% mais je crois que
c'est ça donc on voit qu'il y a un vrai
problème là-dessus est-ce que
l'éducation nationale joue vraiment le
jeu
permettez-moi d'en douter mais enfin bon
là il y a quelque chose à faire en
revanche une autre question importante
vous nous avez dit qu'il vous fallait
beaucoup d'argent pour faire tout ça et
que vous alliez en trouver dans le PLF
j'ai une question très importante et qui
ne tient particulièrement à coeur vous
dites que vous allez prélever sur les
fonds dédiés à l'insertion
professionnelle des personnes
handicapées 29 millions à plusieurs
reprises est-ce que c'est 29 millions IR
ont à la formation des personnes
handicapées ou est-ce que ces 29
millions vont aller un peu partout pour
tout le monde c'est une question très
précise à laquelle j'aimerais beaucoup
monsieur le ministre que vous me
répondiez et je pense que Claire-Lise
Campion ma collègue sera effectivement
très intéressée elle aussi d'avoir votre
réponse je vous remercie monsieur
merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre de nombreux jeunes
ne trouvent plus actuellement de travail
en France comme vous le savez et ils
sont nombreux à être tentés de le
chercher ailleurs
beaucoup font le choix donc de la
mobilité professionnelle ici je trouve
que nous avons au budget de l'action
extérieure de l'État
une ligne emploi formation de 800.000
euros c'est une somme qui vient d'être
supprimée
cela va menacer de nombreux services
d'accompagnement à l'emploi j'en veux
pour preuve un courrier de mon collègue
Christophe Rassat qui s'est adressé au
ministre des Affaires étrangères et du
développement international qui a
expliqué les conséquences pour le poste
de Buenos Aires où ça va menacer le
service à l'emploi qui trouve 150 ans
par an demande de stage aussi venant de
France
le Centre Charles Peggy à Londres qui
place mille personnes par an et pour un
coût pour l'État de 60 euros à peu près
par job ce sont ceux qu'on appelle les
oubliés de s'impancras ils arrivent avec
un sac sur le dos à la gare de
Saint-Pancras à Londres et il tape à la
porte de Charles Péguy et il trouve un
travail généralement dans les trois
quatre jours
nous avons des comités consulaires dans
chaque consulat qui travaille ce qui
réfléchissent sur ces questions
d'emplois formation professionnelle et
qui avait ce petit budget qui les aide
et justement pour pour faire ses
placements
la mobilité professionnelle est
aujourd'hui une nécessité à titre
personnel moi à Londres je suis inondé
de demande de stage qui m'arrive de
France et c'est normal ça fait partie de
la formation professionnelle d'apprendre
l'anglais aujourd'hui on en a besoin et
c'est souvent en allant en Angleterre
que les gens les jeunes
acquièrent cette compétence donc nous
avons besoin d'accompagner une dynamique
qui facite ses expériences à l'étranger
accompagne des stages et facilite le
retour en France
serait-il possible d'envisager au niveau
du ministère de l'Emploi la reprise en
compte de cette action qui est
abandonnée par le mystère des Affaires
étrangères donc pour puisque je pense
que pour un budget tout à fait minime il
y a un véritable intérêt pour l'intérêt
général et le public et le grand public
merci merci monsieur le ministre pour
toutes les précisions que vous nous avez
données mais j'aimerais que vous nous
précisiez dans un domaine surtout celui
des ruptures conventionnelles qu'est-ce
que ça fait maintenant quelques années
que ne subissons ces ruptures
conventionnelles et parmi le chômage qui
a annoncé il y a un moment donné on nous
disait qu'il y avait un million 400 000
chômeurs
issus des ruptures conventionnelles donc
je voudrais savoir si ces ruptures par
rapport à ces ruptures si derrière il y
a eu de l'embauche ou non ou et puis
surtout ces ruptures conventionnelles
aujourd'hui elles sont plutôt le
résultat justement des pré-retraite
entre guillemets puisque ce sont des
gens vous l'avez dit des personnes
souvent qui ont 58 ans 57 ans qui voilà
on trouve un malaise dans l'entreprise
revenons aussi sur les maisons de
l'emploi mais surtout sur les missions
locales
j'ai fait un rapport sur les
collectivités l'emploi il y a deux ans
où c'était très intéressant de savoir
que par exemple à Marseille il y avait
plus de 400 missions locales qui
travaillaient en parallèle avec maison
d'emploi et donc est-ce qu'il faudrait
pas revoir toutes ces structures
effectivement et voir celles qui sont
compétitives et donner un peu plus de
budget dans
Mission Locale donc pour vous dire qu'il
fallait quand même revoir certains
certaines régions et certaines villes
comment elles fonctionnent juste
revenir aussi sur l'apprentissage
j'entends depuis quelques années je suis
sénatrice depuis 10 ans revenir chaque
année sur l'apprentissage mais peu de
sénateurs ont un enfant ou ont passé par
un apprentissage et non pas le le
parcours d'un enfant qui est passé par
là le mien est passé par là il a fait un
cap un bac pro et effectivement
il y a beaucoup de jeunes qui sont
volontaires et veulent partir dans
l'apprentissage mais souvent c'est
justement les maîtres d'apprentissage
qui sont pas tellement ne font pas
tellement d'efforts et ont quand on
entend du matin on soit vous êtes vous
nous revenez trop cher quand ils ont 16
ans 17 ans 18 ans je pense que quand on
va par rapport à l'effort et à au
travail qui font même déjà à partir de
16 ans je crois qu'il faut aussi revoir
beaucoup de choses et surtout
aujourd'hui le problème qui est qui est
en qui est vraiment on constate c'est
ceux qui veulent aller en altinence en
alternance pour un BTS puisque les
entreprises ne veulent plus embaucher
puisqu'ils sont elles sont obligées de
de financer mais surtout dire que quand
on part pour un BTS c'est qu'on a déjà
une formation donc que derrière on
apporte beaucoup dans l'entreprise
monsieur café
merci monsieur le Président j'ai
monsieur le ministre j'ai une question
qui déborde le cadre de strict du budget
de votre ministère mais qui néanmoins me
semble présenter un intérêt en fait pour
les finances publiques
la collectivité nationale consacre à
travers le cice et le pape de
responsabilité un effort tout à fait
considérable en faveur des entreprises
et dans l'objectif bien évidemment de
faire le maximum pour le mode d'emploi
je parlais ici je fais tout le monde les
connaît en 2017 ce sera 40 milliards
et bien évidemment se pose la question
en fait de l'efficacité de cette dépense
alors pour le cice les résultats dont on
dispose pour le moment mais qui sont
temporaires et qui viennent de France
stratégie semble montrer en fait que le
cice est utilisé par les entreprises
principalement pour l'investissement
pour le développement de peu à l'emploi
et pas pour la distribution de
dividendes comme on l'entend parfois
sur le pack de responsabilité il n'y a
pas de véritable études qui sont
disponibles mais on a le sentiment quand
même que
l'esprit des contreparties qui animait
ce pacte de responsabilité contrepartie
avec les entreprises à quand même du mal
à prendre au corps bon et alors je n'ai
jamais été moi partisan en fait des
objectifs chiffrés
décliner et parfois entreprise par
entreprise comme on a pu entendre la
proposition de la part de la sacrément
pour parlementaires mais il semblerait
quand même que les engagements en faveur
des entreprises et du monde de patronal
pour l'utilisation de cette manne en
faveur de l'emploi et notamment au
niveau des branches dans les discussions
de branches bon ne soit pas à la hauteur
de ce qu'on pouvait attendre donc ma
question est est-ce que vous pouvez nous
faire le point sur ces négociations de
branches ces discussions de branches et
que peut-on en espérer dans veut dire
que nous espérons tous proches Monsieur
Jean Santa
merci monsieur le Président merci
Monsieur le Ministre alors selon les
régions et départements on a un regard
sur les maisons de l'emploi sur
l'émission locale moi je veux revenir et
comme on a peu de temps et si on veut
vous laisser nous répondre il faut aller
vite je vais vers
dans une situation sociale difficile
l'économique et sociale difficile les
ceux qui souffrent le plus sont les
jeunes et ceux qui souffrent encore plus
ce sont les jeunes des pourvues de
diplômes en rupture avec l'éducation en
rupture familiale parfois et il pousse
ils n'ont plus qu'une seule chose à
pousser ça apporte des missions locales
et vous avez à travers l'engagement et
vous l'avez répété fortement
188,8 millions d'euros 269 avec les
expérimentations de la garantie jeune
vous redonnez aussi avec les emplois
d'avenir vous redonnez des outils au
conseiller c'est-à-dire que quand on
pousse la porte de la Mission Locale
aujourd'hui on a des possibilités de
sortie et de construire des parcours
d'insertion sociale et professionnelle
pour les jeunes moins de 25 et moi je
salue votre directive en direction des
directions régionales de ne pas déroger
pour les emplois d'avenir d'avoir
vraiment le public cible c'est-à-dire
les jeunes sans diplôme parce que nous
il serait resté automatiquement au bord
de la route il n'aurait aucune solution
d'entrer dans la vie active et à travers
votre démarche alors certes on a il faut
parfois déroger
parce qu'on arrive à parfois entendre
mais finalement mon fils a eu le bac il
aurait mieux valu qu'il rate parce qu'il
aurait été dans les publics
prioritaires pour les emplois d'avenir
voilà alors on a des petites il faut se
réserver une petite dérogation possible
mais en tous les cas vous avez redonné
du sens parce que les missions locales
ce sont des associations on retrouve des
élus locaux des responsables patronaux
syndicaux
un territoire économique alors sa
caricature que nous donne Patricia moi
dans mon département il y a une mission
locale départementale donc
et qui coordonne l'action sur l'ensemble
du territoire d'un petit département
certes mais voilà non on a décidé avec
l'État d'avoir ce schéma là et
aujourd'hui l'émission locale donc sont
en première ligne moi je salue l'effort
qui est fait je le redis encore
fortement nous sommes l'émission locale
de ma région discute actuellement avec
les conseils régionaux des
conventions plus réelles d'objectifs et
de moyens et il se trouve
j'ai entendu avec satisfaction dans
votre intervention une compensation
intégrale de prime de l'apprentissage de
la prime d'apprentissage aux régions là
ma question c'est celle-ci je veux
l'entendre de nouveau fortement puisque
les régions la région Limousin nous
annonce des baisses en direction des
missions locales parce que justement il
n'y aurait pas une compensation
intégrale et voilà j'entends qu'il y a
65 millions d'euros en direction des
régions une compensation intégrale donc
voilà c'est ma question
est dans ce sens en sachant que
l'émission locale aujourd'hui sont
véritablement des remparts et la
garantie jeune un rempart important
contre la pauvreté
président monsieur le ministre je
voudrais faire trois remarques la
première concerne les emplois aidés dans
les collectivités vous nous avez dit
Madame Touraine nous a dit aussi que ces
emplois aidés correspondent à de vraies
besoins notamment à l'éducation
nationale n'ont pas la fois sans y jouer
parce que les jeunes accomplissent
devraient tâches et en même temps moi je
pense qu'il faut aussi qu'on ait un
regard
à plus longue vue parce que peut-être
qu'un jour cette crise de l'emploi
extrêmement difficile sera un peu moins
difficile mais que je ne pense pas que
nous rentrerons dans une civilisation où
le plein emploi sera une règle et qu'il
faudra sans doute se faire à l'idée
qu'on aura des allers-retours entre
l'emploi et le non-emploi ce qui posent
bien la question de la formation
professionnelle tout au long de la vie
qu'il ne faut pas gérer qu'au moment de
crise pour revenir à la question des
employés dans les collectivités ou les
collectivités font preuve d'un civisme
qui saluer parce qu'on doit être
solidaire dans un moment aussi difficile
moi j'ai beaucoup de crainte sur la
sortie du dispositif c'est-à-dire quand
on sera au bout de ce dispositif de
contrats et des et cela a été rappelé
tout à l'heure par une de mes collègues
les collectivités ne pourront pas garder
et financer des postes qui aujourd'hui
correspondent à un vrai besoin et on a
connu ça avec d'autres dispositifs donc
moi je ne dis pas qu'il fallait pas le
faire mais je pense qu'il faut qu'on
anticipe aussi cette question mon
troisième point concerne l'apprentissage
on en a beaucoup parlé et je suis
heureuse monsieur le ministre que vous
en parler autant et je le dis très
sincèrement mais en même temps moi je
pense qu'on parle d'apprentissage que
quand ça va mal et alors on met un coup
de projecteur sur l'apprentissage en
ayant l'air de découvrir de manière
assez régulière que c'est une vraie
filière de réussite et à miracle c'est
une vraie filière de réussite mais je
pense et tout le monde l'a dit qu'on a
en France un un problème culturel sur
l'apprentissage j'ai fait la remarque
l'autre jour à Madame tourinque qui nous
a expliqué que la revalorisation des
allocations familiales interviendraient
quand l'enfant aurait 16 ans parce que
c'est l'âge du lycée ça veut dire que
quand on écrit des choses comme ça
personne ne pense qu'il y a aussi des
jeunes qui a 16 ans font d'autres choix
de vie donc ça c'est un vrai un vrai
problème et que moi je pense qu'il faut
que effectivement si on veut valoriser
l'apprentissage il faut le faire
connaître il faut qu'on ait des
campagnes de promotion de
l'apprentissage sur les métiers les
métiers qui existent montrer des jeunes
qui sont en voie de réussite qui ont
démarré au bas de l'échelle et qui ont
eu des vrais progressions c'est comme ça
mais de manière récurrente qu'on fera
passer les messages et Madame a raison
je pense que le jour où chacun d'entre
nous sera fier d'avoir un enfant qui a
été apprenti les choses iront mieux et
on a aussi une vraie question sur le
rapport avec l'Éducation nationale parce
qu'aujourd'hui la formation
professionnelle monsieur le ministre
dans votre ministère et les gens qui
font de l'orientation sont dans le
ministère de l'Éducation nationale et
que quand il parle de l'alternance il
parle de l'alternance dans les lycées
donc moi je pense que c'est aussi une
bonne chose sauf que nous avons de
vraies difficultés aujourd'hui pour que
les entreprises accueillent tous les
jeunes qui ont des périodes de stage au
même moment et que moi je pense qu'il
faut aussi un lien entre les gens qui
font l'orientation et le et la formation
professionnelle et moi je me demande
pourquoi par exemple les écoles de
commerce ne relèvent pas de votre
ministère alors que c'est de la
formation professionnelle tout autant
que des CFA et enfin je voudrais aussi
reprendre ce qui est dit tout à l'heure
par une de mes collègues sur la garantie
jeune moi je suis je me dis il est bien
qu'on soit solidaire des jeunes
complètement désorientés mais Monsieur
le Ministre avoir un enfant en
apprentissage c'est un coup puisque
quand vous avez un enfant en
apprentissage dans une entreprise
parfois il doit avoir deux lieux
d'habitation le lieu du CFA et le lieu
de l'entreprise est parfois 3 plus je le
transport plus les outils qu'il faut
acheter donc moi j'aimerais bien que
cette garantie jeune elle soit aussi un
peu fléchés à destination des jeunes qui
s'engagent courageusement dans la vie
professionnelle
si vous reste 8 minutes pour répondre à
toutes ces questions
bon d'abord merci merci de participer
à la réflexion merci monsieur le
Président je vais essayer de répondre
très précisément il y a eu une question
très générale sur les maisons de
l'emploi
je comprends en plus il y a des maisons
de l'emploi qui qui travaille bien et
puis il y en a qui sont moins efficaces
on va dire des choses comme ça d'abord
elle ne couvre qu'un tiers du territoire
national elle marche bien quand elles
sont en lien avec un bassin d'emploi ça
a été dit par les uns et par les autres
donc moi j'ai il va dire les choses
clairement j'ai sauvé le budget de
fonctionnement des maisons de l'emploi
quand on fait des économies on cherche
partout et voilà donc j'ai maintenu le
budget de fonctionnement j'ouvre la
possibilité aux appels à projet d'aller
frapper aux portes des directs pour
demander les aides GPEC qui sont là
territoriales donc celles qui
fonctionnent voilà j'envisage de mettre
en place une mission parlementaire pour
essayer il y a des bonnes missions il y
a des bonnes maisons de l'emploi et il y
en a d'autres qui sont moins bonnes il
faut il faudrait trouver pour le moment
on l'a pas fait les critères qui
permettaient d'améliorer
le fonctionnement des bonnes donné plus
enfin je veux dire les choses comme ça
donner plus aux bonnes d'ailleurs il y a
des collectivités locales qui aident
beaucoup les maisons de l'emploi il y a
des collectivités locales qui n'ont pas
du tout la Maison de l'Emploi donc moi
j'ai demandé à voir un tableau je
m'engage à vous le fournir précis Maison
de l'emploi par Maison de l'emploi de la
quête financement etc madame procacia
elle est souvent très très pertinente
dans ces remarques c'est vrai que
moi-même à Dijon je peux donner mon
expérience j'ai créé une maison de
l'emploi monsieur Borlo a lancé ça je me
suis lancé dedans on l'a fait avec sur
le bassin d'emploi c'était une maison de
l'emploi et de la formation on faisait
des voilà et puis il y a eu quand même
une politique d'État national qui a
consisté à fusionner c'est vrai l'ANPE
et Assedic pour faire Pôle emploi et on
a donné et je continue je vais pas dire
au contraire continue de donner des
missions à Pôle emploi qui relevaient en
partie des missions des maisons de
l'emploi précédemment et donc il y a là
aujourd'hui un effort de rationalisation
à faire il faut je crois cibler plus les
maisons de l'emploi sur la prospective
la réflexion sur le bassin d'emploi sur
les formations nécessaires qualifiantes
celles qui correspondent et plus du tout
sur ce qu'elle faisait avant puisque
elles n'ont plus à faire de placement
c'est le rôle de pôle emploi et de Pôle
emploi et d'autres structures mais il y
a les plis etc il faut essayer de
simplifier donc voilà ce que je voulais
vous dire j'ai lancé un travail aussi
avec alliance ville emploi avec les
collectivités pour voir tout cela donc
mais pour le moment il y a un rapport
qui a été fait par Madame bouyaguet sur
le bilan moi je m'engage à vous donner
toutes les informations nécessaires et
voir comment on peut encore améliorer
plus finement les les crédits affectés
aux maisons de
je vais pas reprendre de ce que tout le
monde m'a demandé mais il y a des choses
qui se recoupent une question générale
qui a été évoquée par Monsieur monsieur
monsieur café sur
les engagements réciproques on va dire
les
401 milliards d'euros de retour pour
augmenter la compétitivité des
entreprises pour le moment la vérité et
c'est pour ça que j'ai dit l'autre jour
on peut pas vouloir que ça aille plus
vite que ça ne va la vérité c'est que
c'est la première année où le cice entre
en réalité pour les entreprises
aujourd'hui et encore qu'à hauteur de
4%. donc ça sera à hauteur de 6% en 2015
et donc on peut pas porter jugement à
l'avance de ce qui va se passer mais il
y a un suivi qui montre que il y a de
l'investissement qui se fait pas
forcément et vous aviez raison pas
forcément d'ailleurs directement sur
l'emploi mais sur l'investissement mais
c'est bien l'investissement c'est bien
et donc c'est pas forcément directement
de l'emploi c'est de l'investissement
mais on va pas dire comme disait
mouchmidt c'est les emplois de demain
mais enfin sûrement ça représente des
emplois de demain ça c'est clair et je
voudrais je voudrais ajouter sur le pack
vous m'avez demandé il y a aujourd'hui
j'ai réuni 50 branches et vous savez il
y a 700 branches en France c'est donc on
va les réduire et tout le monde est
d'accord on va passer sûrement à un
horizon de 100 sur 10 ans mais ça va
proposer des problèmes bien évidemment
en tous les cas on va on va réduire et
j'ai réuni les 50 plus importantes et 50
plus importantes elles couvre près de 12
millions de salariés c'est pas rien
là-dessus sur les 50 il y en a 44 qui
ont commencé il y en a qui ont signé il
y en a qui sont avancés il y en a qui
ont élaboré un calendrier et puis il y
en a 6 qui n'ont rien fait
elle concerne dont une la branche des
experts-comptables ça fait à peu près
000 personnes concernées
ils sont réunis puis ils ont dit qu'il
voulait rien faire donc voilà c'est
simple c'est parce que ce sont des
professions qui aujourd'hui
sont ce qu'on appelle des professions
réglementées et je pense que il y a un
lien entre les deux donc on va voir
comment on peut débloquer cela voilà
mais c'est pas acceptable c'est pas
acceptable je dis je ne citerai pas les
5 autres branches mais
je crois qu'il allait les officines de
pharmacie il y a les cabinets médicaux
il y a les concierges et gardiens
d'immeubles et il y a la restauration
je crois la restauration collective je
crois voilà les cinq branches plus les
experts comptables voilà ceux qui pour
le moment mes experts comptables eux ils
ont réunis ils ont dit non les autres
sont pas encore réunis voilà on verra
tout cela je continue excusez-moi
j'essaie de d'avancer l'insertion par
l'activité économique se mouillé oui
mais on va continuer il faut pas avoir
de crainte sur l'aide au poste ça va ça
va le faire très bien
on va on va y arriver je les ai
rencontré moi j'ai été les voir j'ai été
voir comment ça fonctionnait il l'avait
demandé on les a beaucoup aidés depuis 2
ans à cet égard je voudrais quand même
dire oui le budget il a un peu baissé il
a baissé monsieur mauriceem l'a dit
aussi il a baissé de 1% mais ce qu'on
oublie de dire c'est qu'il a augmenté
25% depuis 2012 quand même je me permets
de le dire donc quand on est arrivé il
était en dessous de 10 milliards il
était de 9 milliards 6 et il est
aujourd'hui de 11 milliards 3 alors
voilà bon c'est vrai que il est étal
cette année voir les j'ai recul mais bon
pour les deux postes je maintiens nous
allons y arriver les contrats aidés oui
madame je crois que c'est Madame Gatel
qui m'a dit que les il y a un problème
le financement pour les collectivités
locales mais ça coûte pas très cher aux
collectivités locales c'est à l'État que
ça ah oui mais au collectivité locale et
encore il y en a qui en prennent pas il
y en a qui en prennent pas ce qui est
pas bien d'ailleurs chacun se débrouille
il fait ce qu'il veut c'est la liberté
des collectivités locales mais c'est 80
85 % de financement donc quand même
d'État donc voilà et ça aide quand même
à condition qu'il y a la durée je le
redis à condition qu'il est la durée et
la durée c'est un an on arrive vers un
an d'ailleurs avec
11,3 pour le moment là la garantie alors
l'insertion par l'activité économique
n'ayez pas de crainte les crédits sont
là on y travaille je suis ça de près
j'ai dans ma région la plus gros groupe
d'entreprise d'insertion et on peut les
suivre on peut regarder j'étais voir
ça fonctionne ils ont eu les crédits qui
voulaient et on va on va suivre ça la
garantie jeune c'est un vrai c'est un
vrai débat c'est un vrai débat il a été
posé par Madame progacia c'est une
initiative européenne c'est l'initiative
européenne l'Europe mais sur la table 6
milliards virgule 5 et nous enfin moi
j'aimerais bien qu'on en mette encore
plus mais s'il y a 5 pour les jeunes qui
sont ce qu'ils appellent les mythes
c'est-à-dire ceux qui sont sans emploi
sans stage sans formation et qui sont
même en France de décrocheurs
j'ajoute que ça serait bien aussi
d'arrêter le flux des décrocheurs chaque
année ça c'est en amont parce que on
peut ça coûte très cher à la société en
aval on est je pense tous d'accord on
estime à on dit 150000 mais en disant il
y a bien 130 000 chaque année voilà qui
en plus se retrouve sur le marché du
travail bien souvent
volontairement à volontairement se
retrouve sur le marché du travail en
tous les cas demandeurs d'emploi
demandeur d'emploi et il y a 600 000
départs en retraite chaque année 600 000
départs en retraite mais il y a en
France 740 000 arrivées sur le marché du
travail donc non seulement il faut
stabiliser mais il faut avoir plus de
poste en Allemagne c'est l'inverse donc
c'est vrai que c'est plus facile quand
vous en avez moi mais pour l'avenir
c'est mieux d'avoir plus de jeunes je le
crois et je le dis même s'il faut les
assumer garantie jeunes donc la France
elle elle est concernée à hauteur de 10%
de l'enveloppe
européenne 660 millions d'euros
l'Espagne c'est un milliard 4 ou 1
milliard trois et demi le
ça va être 900 millions d'euros etc donc
on peut pas pour une fois que l'Europe
met en place un dispositif voilà alors
c'est pas c'est pas j'ai entendu parce
que le débat il existe et c'est une
bonne question les RSA RSA jeune sorte
de RSA socle non il y a un
accompagnement qui sera fait par
l'émission locale d'ailleurs il y a des
crédits d'accompagnement parce que si le
jeûne il touche 445 euros par mois en
compensation il doit aller faire des
stages en immersion en entreprise j'ai
rencontré des jeunes dans des forums
d'emploi des jeunes qui sont en garantie
jeune et ils sont
ils sont très heureux parce qu'ils ont
trouvé de l'immersion en entreprise
uniquement parce qu'ils avaient la
garantie jeune et qu'ils étaient
accompagnés par l'émission locale donc
ça un facteur je crois d'accompagnement
ça a été demandé c'est une demande qui a
été formulée par les partenaires sociaux
à la fin de la grande conférence sociale
on était sur 10000 on en a fait
très exactement 6 dans un sens 7000
peut-être à l'heure où on parle et donc
il va falloir faire un un gap important
pour arriver à 50000 l'année prochaine
bon mais il faut veiller à ce que ça ne
soit pas une allocation
d'assistanat j'ai entendu et ça doit
être c'est pour ça qu'il y a un suivi et
chaque mission locale il y a 1600 euros
qui sont versés par jeunes pour
l'accompagnement et le suivi donc c'est
c'est important sinon il ça marche pas
sinon c'est exactement ce que ce qui a
été dit et dénoncé
est-ce que j'ai oublié beaucoup de
choses oui là j'ai FIP madame Debré oui
il y a une ponction qui est faite de 29
millions d'euros
c'est vrai aussi sur le FPF
fonction publique FP merci c'est vrai
aussi du même montant 29 millions
d'euros les deux ont des réserves
dormantes de
de j'ai dit pour
le
fonction publique la station d'infosse
au public des personnes handicapées
c'est 394 millions qui a donc voilà on
peut s'emporter atteinte à cela est-ce
que ça va servir c'est le sens de votre
question est-ce que ça va servir oui il
y a aujourd'hui
on finance à peu près
20.000 emplois aidés
de de personnes en situation de handicap
pour des handicapés pour des handicapés
20000 emplois aidés pour des handicapés
il y en avait 5000 en 2013
50000 pourquoi ah oui avec les 60 000
oui bon alors on en a en réalité 10000
en plus multiplié par deux ça va faire
20 000 de plus emplois et des
spécifiquement tournés vers les
personnes handicapées et donc
j'ai rencontré d'ailleurs
la présidente de la Gifi pour pour lui
dire c'est géré par les partenaires
sociaux
est-ce que je dois dire ça non si je dis
ça ça va immédiatement voilà il y a donc
deux fonds voilà je n'en dirai pas plus
on pourrait travailler en meilleure
coordination voilà je pense je crois que
tout le monde a compris le sentiment qui
m'anime dire également
dit également que je n'oublie rien les
ruptures conventionnelles c'était madame
chilinger oui il y a eu il y a eu
beaucoup il y a eu un mouvement de
rupture conventionnelle maintenant il y
a des différer qui sont pris en compte
par
l'assurance chômage mais c'est vrai que
c'était un peu difficile de comprendre
que 453 cadres de Pôle Emploi bénéficie
de ruptures conventionnelle avant de
s'inscrire à Pôle emploi quand même
c'est quand même un peu difficile
c'était le résultat de la fusion où il y
avait plus de cadres que nécessaire et
moins de conseillers ces deux cultures
voilà
plus ceux qui sont inscrits aujourd'hui
dans les les dispositif et qui sont
dispensés de recherche d'emploi des
facto parce que il y a une sorte de tout
le monde le sait de pré-retraite comme
cela qui peut se permettre aux
entreprises de le faire donc il faut
faire en sorte de limiter les mais les
entreprises sont très de demanderaient
ou demandeuses je sais pas comment il
faut dire de ce dispositif des ruptures
conventionnelles
moi je suis plus réservé voilà mais
il faut il faut tenir compte de cela
c'est me dit-on une facilité sur
l'émission locale le nombre de missions
locales
en général ça fonctionne très bien c'est
très bien et je vais pas regarder dans
dans les territoires ce que je sais
c'est que c'est bien suivi ça ça
fonctionne bien sur l'apprentissage
d'une manière générale vous avez tous
raison moi je suis et on est tous
confrontés au problème et ça a été dit
par le rapporteur au départ
j'ai présidé la Commission de la
formation professionnelle conseil
régional il y a quelques temps dans ma
jeunesse on va dire et donc
je voyais bien l'apprentissage des
objectifs était quantitativement
toujours les mêmes 500500 1500 000 les
ministres du travail sont succédés en
disant ça 100500000 l'actuel président
du Sénat avait dit 500000 on n'a jamais
dépassé les 400000 et là on a perdu 8 %,
c'est vrai mais on a perdu 8 % on a un
problème de jeune qui arrive pas à
trouver des stages en entreprise quand
même faut quand même le dire on trouve
certains jeunes se découragent parce
qu'ils envoient 50 lettres pour trouver
une entreprise qui accepte de les
accueillir et par contre quand je
rencontre les entreprises elles sont
très d'accord avec l'apprentissage elles
disent toutes ces formidables voilà les
partenaires sociaux tout le monde dit
c'est formidable donc j'espère que
puisque tout le monde dit que c'est
formidable que c'est stabilisé que qu'on
fait une campagne je voulais vous le
dire on a fait une campagne nationale de
promotion consacrée aujourd'hui chaque
euro dépensé et compte plus d'un million
d'euros on a pu prendre des entreprises
qui parle aux jeunes on a fait la Fnac
par exemple avec Monsieur Bompard donc
je pense qu'on va y arriver je pense
qu'on va y arriver mais il faut plus
qu'on change de dispositif voilà donc je
veillerai je sais plus qui a dit cela je
verrai ce que Monsieur Macron ne
viennent pas modifier cela
on fera les choses ensemble mais il y a
pas de raison de de modifier plus que
cela les choses
voilà je suis le président j'ai
peut-être élu des certaines questions
mais pas par volonté de le faire en tous
les cas
et oui ici la question que vous m'avait
posée monsieur caddic sur comité
consulaire c'est pas
je regrette mais il faudra demander au
ministre concerné
je peux pas prendre ce genre de
sur mon budget j'ai pas la place pour
prendre ça donc voilà c'est mais je n'en
dis pas l'utilité il faudra voir avec le
ministre concerné
voilà merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre bon vous n'avez que 9 minutes
de retard ça va aller pour le reste
du travail qui a été auditionné par la
Commission
des sur le projet de loi de finances
pour 2015 l'ancien sénateur a défendu
son bilan il a d'ailleurs été attaqué
par plusieurs sénateurs de droite sur et
bien l'efficacité des emplois et des sur
les contrats d'avenir sur les contrats
de génération il a également défendu son
budget pour 2015 qui va évoluer dans un
contexte très contraint mais je le cite
c'est un budget de mobilisation pour
plus d'efficacité dans la politique de
l'emploi pour demain un budget qui sera
également tout particulièrement orienté
vers la jeunesse rappelons que François
Rebsamen a récemment concédé l'échec du
gouvernement dans la lutte contre le
chômage même si il a estimé que c'était
un échec collectif un échec qui ne date
pas d'hier il a d'ailleurs tout à
l'heure déclaré dans la même veine que
là depuis des années structurellement la
France a fait le choix d'un chômage de
masse cela par un marché du travail où
il est très difficile de rentrer pour
ceux qui n'y sont pas encore inséré
voilà donc pour cette audition de
François Rebsamen une audition qui vient
de se conclure tout de suite je vous
propose de revenir à un temps fort de la
séance hier soir cette nuit c'était lors
de l'examen du projet de loi sur la
simplification de la vie des entreprises
à l'initiative de la droite les
sénateurs ont adopté la suppression du
compte de prévention de la pénibilité
l'une des mesures phares de la réforme
des retraites c'était une demande du
Medef qui réclamait cette suppression
jugeant que ce compte était inapplicable
et anxiogène pour les entreprises tout
de suite donc retour à la séance tant
pour les entreprises que pour les
salariés afin d'éviter la multiplication
des contentieux sur les facteurs
d'exposition et l'attribution de points
s'y rapportant
il convient de ne pas introduire de
nouvelles formes de conflictualité
sociale au sein de l'entreprise cet
amendement propose d'introduire une
procédure de rescrit simplifiée sur la
prise en compte de l'exposition facteur
de pénibilité il s'agirait pour les
entreprises